وفي اولى ردود الفعل الاوكرانيه اعتبرت
الرئاسه الاوكرانيه ان تفجير سد كخوفك
يهدف الى ابطاء الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد
من جهه يعتبر الرئيس الاوكراني فولودي
ميرسي ان تدمير سد نوفاكا يؤكد للعالم انه
يجب طرد من سماهم الارهابيين الروس من كل
زاويه من الارض الاوكرانيه واضاف ان
الارهابيين لن يتمكنوا من ايقاف تزويد
اوكرانيا بالمياه او الصواريخ او اي شيء
اخر بدوره قال رئيس الوزراء الاوكراني
دينيسيا شمينال ان تفجير القوات الروسيه
سدك خوفك عمل ارهابي يهدد باغراق ما يصل
الى 80 بلده اوكرانيه وانه يجري تقييم
العواقب على البيئه والتهديد المحتمل
لمحطه زابوروجيا للطاقه النوويه اما وزير
الخارجيه الاوكراني ديمتروكوليبا فاعتبر
ان تدمير روسيا للسد قد يؤدي الى اكبر
كارثه تكنولوجيه في اوروبا منذ عقود ويعرض
الاف المدنيين
للخطر
رئيس الوزراء حسان يتحدث ايضا عن عمليات
اجلاء للسكان المناطق التي غمرتها المياه
باتجاه
ميكوليف عن طريق القطارات بالاضافه ايضا
الى اتهامات اوكرانيه قربنا من المشهد
هناك
نعم سهام هو حدث كبير له ارتدادات على
اكثر من مستوى على المستوى
السكاني والبيئي وكذلك على المستوى
المرتبط بالخطر
المحدق المرتبط بمحطه زق النوويه بالاضافه
ايضا الى الارتدادات السياسيه وحتى
الميدانيه
المرتبطه بالهجوم المضاد الاوكراني كل ذلك
يرتبط بهذا الحدث الكبير
مرتبط بتفجير محطه كخوفكا الكهرومائيه
الواقعه على سد كخوفكا عند نهر دينيبرو
بين ضيفتي النهر ضفه اليسرى التي تسيطر
عليها القوات الروسيه والضفه اليمنى التي
تسيطر عليها
القوات والجانب الاوكراني كذلك الا ان عدد
من التطورات برزت خلال الساعات الاخيره
والدقائق حتى الاخيره نبدا من المعطيات
الميدانيه حيث اعلن قبل قليل الرئيس
الاداره العسكريه في منطقه خرسون وتحديدا
المنطقه الخاضعه لسيطره الجانب الاوكراني
وهي الضفه اليمنى ان تسع بلدات غمرتها
المياه بشكل كلي او جزئي حتى هذه اللحظه
في منطقه
خرسون وهي مناطق واقعه عند اطراف مدينه
خرسون وقد بدات عمليات الاجلاء بالحافلات
نحو مدينه خرسون ومنها سيتم تنظيم عمليات
اجلاء للسكان من تلك المناطق وكذلك من
مدينه خرسون نحو مدينه ميكو لايف الجنوبيه
الواقعه شمالي مقاطعه خرسون وهناك ستتم
عمليات تنظيم هذه العمليات الاجلاء التي
ستبدا بشكل مباشر منذ الساعه الثانيه عشره
ظهرا بعد ساعتين من الان من المرتقب ان
يتم اجلاء اكثر من سته عشر الف شخص حتى
هذه اللحظه وهي المناطق التي تصنف على
انها مناطق حرجه في منطقه الضفه اليمنى من
نهر دنيفرو وكل ذلك هو وفق المعطيات
الاوليه لان رئيس الاداره العسكريه يحذر
من ان عدد البلدات التي يمكن ان تغمرها
المياه يمكن ان يرتفع في اي لحظه وفق
ارتفاع الارتفاع السريع لمنسوب المياه
ونفاذ الخزانات
التي كانت تحتوي على المياه في محطه
كخوفكا الكهرومائيه هذا فيما يرتبطوا
بالمعطى الميداني هناك في خرسون الا ان
عدد كبير ايضا من التصريحات بدات تتوالى
من الجانب الاوكراني ابرز هذه التصريحات
ايضا مؤخرا كانت
لمستشار الرئاسه الاوكرانيه الذي اعتبر
تدمير هذا السد وتفجير هذه المحطه هو
محاوله من الجانب الروسي لابطاء عمليات
الهجوم المضاد الاوكرانيه لاسيما في منطقه
الجنوبيه حمل بشكل واضح المسؤوليه للجانب
الروسي
لتفجير هذا السد وفقه
وجهه النظر الاوكرانيه وفق الروايه
الاوكرانيه هذا الموقف ايضا يشبه الى حد
كبير المواقف التي صدرت عن الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه سواء كان عن الرئيس الاوكراني
الذي يشارك في هذه الاثناء في اجتماع مجلس
الامن القومي والدفاع وهي قياده الاركان
العليا
لاوكرانيا لمتابعه هذا الموضوع وقضيه
تفجير السد هو كان قد اتهم الجانب الروسي
بتدمير السد وبن تنفيذ هذا الهجوم وقال
ووصف هذا الهجوم بالهجوم الارهابي قال ان
ما جرى اليوم هو اكبر نموذج على ضروره
وطرد وفق قوله وفق تعبيره كل القوات
الروسيه من الاراضي الاوكرانيه بشكل كامل
وان على العالم ايضا ان يتحرك ازاء ذلك
وفي ذات الوقت كان هناك تصريحات ايضا
لمدير مكتب الرئاسه الاوكرانيه قال ان
لهذا الامر تداعيات على عدد من
مناطق على عدد من ايضا
المنشات
وايضا الاحتياجات السكانيه
التي ترتبط في المياه بشكل اساسي وتحديدا
في ايصال المياه الى شبه جزيره القرم وهو
حمل المسؤوليه للجانب الروسي بذلك وفي ذات
الوقت فانه ايضا قال ان لهذا الامر
تداعيات حتى على الغذاء العالمي وعلى
عمليات تصدير الغذاء وفق تعبيره وهذا ايضا
يرتبطوا بتحذيرات ايضا اطلقتها هيئه
الطاقه الاوكرانيه ترتبط بان لهذا التفجير
ارتدادات يمكن ان تؤثر على محطه ذابولوجيا
النوويه قالت ان
الخزانات بدات تفرغ في المياه في المحطه
محطه
المحطه الكهربائيه محطه كخوفكا وفي ذات
الوقت هذا يمكن ان يؤثر على المحطه ولكن
ان اكدت ان هذه
التداعيات وهذا الخطر يمكن ان يؤثر على
على المحطه ويمكن ان يكون له تاثير لكن
الوضع حتى هذه اللحظه ما زال تحت السيطره
هناك ايضا حديث
لرئيس الوزراء الاوكرانيه التي قال انه
سيدعو ايضا لجلسه مجلس الوزراء بشكل طارئ
وقال ان هذا
الامر يمكن ان يؤثر هذا التفجير وارتفاع
منسوب المياه يمكن ان يؤثر على اكثر من 80
بل الاوكرانيه بفعل ارتفاع منسوب المياه
ويمكن ان تغمرها المياه قال ان قطارات
سيتم
التامينها للاجلاء من منطقه خرسون باتجاه
منطقه ميكولايف ودعى العالم للاستجابه
لهذا الخطر
ومحاسبه الجانب الروسي على ذلك ايضا كان
هناك دعوه واضحه من
رئيس الوزراء الاوكراني للجانب الروسي
للانسحاب الفوري من محطه الطاقه النوويه
في زاكولوجيا لتمكين الجانب الاوكراني من
العمل على
مواكبتي هذه التداعيات والحد من الاضرار
التي يمكن ان تخلفها ان تخلفها هذه
هجمه التي ايضا يتهم بها الجانب الروسي
هذه التطورات ايضا ترتبط بشكل مباشر
بالتطورات الميدانيه على عدد من المستويات
في الجبهات الاوكرانيه خلال الايام
الماضيه كانت الانظار قد وجهت نحو الجبهه
الشرقيه ونحو التطورات هناك والحديث
الاوكراني عن تنفيذ هجمات في جبهه
خورتيدسيا وهي الجبهه الواقعه شرقيه
اوكرانيا شرق في منطقه وايضا في المنطقه
الجنوبيه للمنطقه الشرقيه تحديدا في
المنطقه القريبه من مقاطعه سابولوجيا كان
كانت هناك الانظار هناك الحديث عن
التطورات الميدانيه لكن المتحدث باسم
قياده عمليات الجنوب ربطت ما حدث اليوم
بما حدث في الايام الاخيره وفي التطورات
الميدانيه وقالت ان القوات الروسيه كانت
تخشى من هذا الهجوم المضاد لذلك لجات الى
هذه الخطوه وقالت ان هذه الخطوه وان كانت
قد فعلتها
القوات الروسيه وفق قولها ووفق اتهامها
الا انها تؤثر بشكل اكبر على سكان الضفه
اليسر من نهر دنيفرو عن تاثيرها على سكان
الضفه اليمنى وهذا ما يعني ان التاثير
الاكبر سيكون على سكان الضفه الخاضعه
لسيطره القوات الروسيه
وعبرت ايضا عن انها ترصد كيف تقوم القوات
الروسيه والجانب الروسي بالاخلاء بشكل
ذاتي من المنطقه الواقعه تحت سيطرتها في
الضفه اليسرى لنهار النيبرو وقالت ان ما
حدث يرتد على الجانب الروسي في هذه
الاثناء وقالت انها ايضا كانت تستعجل
الخطوات المرتبطه بالهجوم المضاد وكانت
تنتظر هذا الهجوم المضاد للجانب الروسي
ولذلك لجات الى هذا النوع من الافعال التي
ايضا وصفتها بالافعال الارهابيه وفق
تعبيرها هذا ايضا يضاف الى دعوه واضحه من
الجانب الاوكراني من عدد من المسؤولين
سواء كان من الرئيس الاداره العسكريه في
مقاطعه خرسون او حتى المتحدثه باسم قياده
عمليات الجنوب للسكان في المنطقه اليسرى
للبدء بالاخلاء بشكل فوري وعدم انتظار
ارتفاع منسوب المياه في تلك الضفه لان ذلك
سيكون له تاثير كبير على تلك المناطق نظرا
للطبيعه الجغرافيه كما يقول المسؤولون
الاوكرانيون لان تلك المنطقه منطقه
الضفه اليسرى لنهر دينيبرو هي منطقه
منخفضه اكثر من المنطقه الواقعه تحت سيطره
القوات الاوكرانيه وهي المنطقه اليمنى وهو
ما يمكن ان يؤدي بالمياه لكي تغمر عدد
اكبر من المناطق هناك عن المناطق التي
ستغمرها في المنطقه على الضفه اليمنى يضاف
الى ذلك ايضا الحديث عن بدء ارتفاع منسوب
المياه بشكل واضح في منطقه السفن وهي
المنطقه
الواقعه في الضفه اليمنى لنهر دينيبرو
ولكن في ذات الوقت هي عند النهر تماما
وهذه المنطقه يبدو انها الاكثر تاثرا حتى
هذه اللحظه بهذا التفجير وارتفاع منسوب
المياه وهناك قطعت الكهرباء وقطعت ايضا
امدادات الغاز ومن الواضح ان عمليات
الاجلاء بدات بشكل مكثف في تلك المنطقه
اسرع من اي منطقه اخرى وهذه المنطقه ممتده
على طول امتداد الضفتين التي تفصل ويفصل
بينهما نهر دينيبرو كذلك رئيس رئيس المكتب
الرئاسي رئيس مكتب الرئاسه الاوكرانيه قبل
قليل ايضا اعتبر هذا الحدث تدمير محطه
كخوفكار الكهرومائيه اكبر كارثه من صنع
الانسان في العالم في العقود الاخيره وفق
تعبيره وقال ان هذا الامر سيؤثر على حياه
مئات الالاف من الاشخاص لسنوات القادمه
واعتبر هذا الحدث ومن قام بهذا الحدث
الجنون لانه يتمثل في تقديم عدد في عدد من
المخاطر على عدد من المستويات التي تشكل
تهديدا عالميا بالنسبه له ووفقه تعبيره في
اخر تصريحاته التي قام بنشرها على قناته
الرسميه على تيليجرام لماذا يشير الى هذا
التاثير الكبير لان هذا التاثير سيمتد على
مساحات كبيره منطقه خرسون هي من المنطقه
المعروفه بانها من اكثر المناطق المخصصه
للزراعه مناطق سهليه واسعه سواء كانت عند
الضفه اليسرى او عند الضفه اليمنى وخمر
هذه المناطق بالمياه في هذه الفتره يمكن
ان يؤثر ايضا على عمليات الزراعه وايضا
عمليات حصد الحبوب في المواسم القادمه اش